Kilicdaroglu
[Musique]
avertir
N'a-t-il pas beaucoup d'espoir ?
rien ne semble avoir changé selon les résultats
il semble
c'est-à-dire une puissance qui n'a pas changé depuis 21 ans.
Vous savez, qu'est-ce qui change pour les Kurdes ?
je ne sais pas mais toi
Les Kurdes votent réellement en Turquie
est décisif
C'est un choix qui révèle
[Musique]
ils nous effraient du fascisme en quelque sorte
les personnes qui ont été frappées
Ils savent ce que votre peuple attend.
Je sais qu'il n'y aura pas de paix, pas d'économie
un changement qui ne sera pas confortable
il n'y a pas d'espoir, donc pas avec l'AKP
[Musique]
Oui, pour l'avenir des enfants.
nous sommes particulièrement inquiets sinon nous avons déjà
Bien
lutter la plupart de notre vie
nous avons traversé, nous dépenserons de toute façon
nous continuerons de la même manière
[Musique]
Ces 20 années ont donc été vraiment difficiles.
mais le pire c'est qu'après ça
5 ans de plus
c'est tellement difficile d'y penser
Puis-je le faire encore 5 ans ?
une autre année
Voici quel âge ont les enfants dans 5 ans
Je veux dire, partira-t-il après 5 ans ?
Qu'en sera-t-il après 5 ans ?
l'incertitude est trop mauvaise
[Musique]